problema 36 del examen de geometría de
california dice lo siguiente cuál es el
área en unidades cuadradas del trapecio
que se muestra ok aquí tenemos un
trapecio perfecto este lado es paralelo
a este estos de acá quién sabe cómo lo
hacemos para encontrar su área a lo
mejor puedes pensar en la fórmula del
área del trapecio y así pero eso puede
confundirte un poco mejor lo que vamos a
hacer es dividir este trapecio en dos
figuras en un rectángulo y en un
triángulo y para eso vamos a trazar este
segmento el que va de este punto y baja
perpendicularmente va entonces con un
poco de suerte esto nos va a permitir
encontrar las dimensiones del rectángulo
y del triángulo con eso sus áreas y
sumarlas para encontrar el área total
bueno pues si bajamos aquí
perpendicularmente este punto está en x
igual a 8 sí porque está coordenadas 8,5
va entonces cuando recorremos desde 0
hasta 8 pues 88 entonces la longitud de
este lado del rectángulo es igual a 8 y
luego cuanto recorremos de 8 hasta 12
pues recorremos otros 4 entonces esta
longitud de acá es igual a 4
y bueno cuanto tenemos de altura en cada
una de las figuras vamos de altura 0
hasta altura 5 entonces esto mide 5 esto
mide 5 y esto mide 5 y dije que aquí
vale todo perpendicularmente entonces
pues ya tenemos un rectángulo y un
triángulo rectángulo de los cuales
podemos encontrar fácilmente sus áreas 5
x 8 es 40 el área de este rectángulo es
40 5 x 4 es 20 entre 12 10 el área de
este triángulo es 10 y entonces el área
total es 40 10 o sea 50 excelente
problema número 37 a éste se le padre
dice la siguiente figura es un cuadrado
con 4 paralelogramo congruentes
interiores 1-2-3-4 congruentes ok e
interiores ok dice cuál es el área en
unidades cuadradas de la región
sombreada bueno pues la región sombreada
consiste en tomar el área del cuadrado
que es 12 al cuadrado o sea 144 144 y a
eso restar
de los cuatro para el logramos de los
cuatro para le logramos pero bueno cada
uno de esos paralelogramo tiene la misma
área porque son paralelo gramos
congruentes entonces basta encontrar el
área de uno de ellos y la fórmula para
el área de un paralelogramo es tomar la
base y multiplicarla por la altura a lo
mejor eso no es tan claro para ti si no
lo has visto antes déjame decirte por
qué de este lado entonces imagínate que
tenemos aquí un paralelogramo más o
menos de este estilo algo así
ahí está entonces imagínate que nos dan
que nos dan bueno es más vamos a tomar
este de aquí que nos dicen que que la
base es 5 esté acá mide 5 y que la
altura desde esa base es 3 entonces esto
de aquí mide 3 entonces yo digo que el
área de este paralelogramo es 3 x 5 o
sea 15 pero no no tienes por qué
creérmelo así ciegamente una forma de
ver a qué se debe eso es tomar este
triangulito de acá que se obtiene
también trazando un ángulo perpendicular
un ángulo de 90 grados y pasando este
triangulito para acá para acá entonces
nos quedaría algo más o menos de este
estilo nos quedaría este lado este lado
donde cortamos este lado de acá este
lado donde donde no habíamos cortado
pero éste lo pasamos para acá entonces
este este se convertiría en este de acá
en este de acá en este de acá y con eso
podemos ver que se completa un
rectángulo con altura 3 y largo 5 que
tiene área 15 y por lo tanto éste
también tiene área 15 porque simplemente
pase uno de los cachos al otro lado vale
bueno entonces cada uno de estos
paralelo gramos tiene área 15 15 y son
44 x 15 60 entonces a 144 tenemos que
restarle 60 y eso es cuánto 144 menos 60
es 84 entonces el área que queda el área
sombreada es 84 o sea que la respuesta
es ve muy bien vamos aquí abajo
vamos al siguiente problema cuál es el
área en metros cuadrados del trapecio
que se muestra otra vez tenemos un
trapecio entonces el plan es encontrar
las dimensiones de este triángulo este
triángulo y este rectángulo y a partir
de eso pues encontrar las áreas y
sumarlas bueno entonces nos dicen que
este rectángulo tiene este lado igual a
6 bueno si este lado es igual a 6
entonces este de acá también es 6 este 6
este 6 entonces esto de acá
cuánto es cuánto es cada uno de estos
lados bueno observa que estos dos
triangulitos deben de ser deben de ser
congruentes porque son triángulos
rectángulos que tienen la misma
hipotenusa que mide 5 metros y tienen
este cateto igual porque son lados del
rectángulo entonces por el teorema de
pitágoras este tercer lado también va a
ser el mismo vale entonces son
congruentes por lo tanto si este lado
mide x este de acá también mide x
y entonces tenemos tenemos bueno estoy
acá dije que mide 66 y entonces tenemos
que x x 6 o sea 2 x lo voy a hacer de
este lado 2 x +
es igual a 12 de aquí restando 6 de
ambos lados tenemos que 2x es igual a 6
y dividiendo entre 2 x es igual a 3
claro esto hasta lo pudimos haber hecho
mentalmente verdad a 12 le quitamos 6
los seis que quedan se reparten este
entre estos dos entonces cada uno de
estos mide 3 entonces éste mide 3 éste
mide 3
muy bien entonces observa ya tenemos dos
pequeños triángulos que son rectángulos
déjame copiarlo por aquí
tenemos dos triángulos dos triángulos
que son triángulos rectángulos en los
cuales sabemos que un lado mide tres que
la hipotenusa mide cinco y queremos
determinar este otro lado bueno pues es
fácil simplemente tenemos que utilizar
el teorema de pitágoras incluso a lo
mejor hasta conozcas este triángulo pero
bueno vamos a hacerlo nos quedaría aquí
le voy a poner ya porque ya usé x
entonces nos quedaría que llega al
cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado y es igual a
5 al cuadrado 5 al cuadrado osea
cuadrada más 9 es igual a 25 o sea que
llegue cuadrada es 25
9 o sea 16 entonces es igual a 4 muy
bien ya es igual a 4 entonces estos
lados que marcamos que miden lo mismo
cada uno de ellos miden miden 4 y eso
está fantástico porque con esto ya
podemos determinar el área de este
rectángulo 6 por 4 24 entonces el área
de este rectángulo es 24 metros
cuadrados y también podemos encontrar el
área de cada uno de estos triangulitos
este sería un medio de la base por la
altura 3 x 4 es 12 entre 2 y 6 entonces
aquí quedaría 6 y de este lado también
quedaría 6
6 muy bien entonces el área es 24 + 12
o sea que es igual a 36 entonces la
respuesta es ve muy bien ese es el
problema 38 vamos al problema 39
problema 39 cuál es el área en pulgadas
cuadradas y del triángulo que se muestra
a este de aquí se ve interesante observa
esto en triángulo equilátero en realidad
es lo que vamos a hacer funciona para
cualquier triángulo equilátero creo que
ya hasta lo hicimos en un en un rombo
que teníamos arriba pero vamos a volver
a hacerlo la idea es la siguiente como
este de aquí es un triángulo equilátero
entonces al bajar la altura llega justo
llega justo al punto medio entonces esto
mide 5 pulgadas y estoy acá también mide
5 pulgadas estos segmentos va pero al
hacer eso al hacer eso se forman sin ahí
está al hacer eso se forman dos
triángulos congruentes este y este de
acá y esos triángulos son rectángulos y
conocemos la hipotenusa y uno de los
lados entonces podemos aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras por ejemplo
el triángulo rectángulo para intentar
encontrar la medida de x cómo le hacemos
lo hacemos de este lado nos quedaría x
al cuadrado más 5 al cuadrado es igual a
10 al cuadrado osea x al cuadrado más 25
es igual a 100 restando 25 de ambos
lados x al cuadrado es igual a 75
entonces x es igual a raíz de 75 y raíz
de 75 lo podemos pensar de la siguiente
forma 75 es igual a 25 por 3
entonces x es igual a raíz de 25 por
raíz de 3 y entonces x es igual a 5 raíz
de 3 entonces eso nos da nos da la
medida x nos da esto de aquí va entonces
eso que acabo de marcar mide 55 raíz de
3 y eso justo es la altura de este
triangulito de la derecha entonces ahora
ya podemos determinar el área de este
triángulo de la derecha haciendo un
medio de la base que 5 por la altura que
5 raíz de 3
de 3 entonces nos quedaría que el área
de este triángulo es 25
por raíz de 13 entre 2 entre 2 y el área
del otro triángulo que también tenemos
que considerar para encontrar el área
total pues es la misma verdad porque los
dos triángulos son congruentes entonces
tenemos dos veces esta área dos veces
esta área el dos se cancela con el dos y
nos queda 25 raíz de 3 opción b 25 raíz
de 3 muy bien vamos a hacer un último
problema vamos a hacer este problema que
dice que es el problema 40 vale entonces
los perímetros de dos cuadrados están en
razón 4 a 9 bueno entonces déjame tomar
aquí un cuadrado saca otro cuadrado
vamos a poner que este tiene el adobe x
entonces todos estos son x el perímetro
es 4x y de este lado vamos a poner que
el lado s
entonces tiene perímetro 4 y lo que nos
dice el enunciado es que la razón de los
perímetros es 49 o sea 4x entre 4 y es
igual a 4 entre 9 va pero observa que
este 4 y este 4 se pueden cancelar
entonces o sea x entre jet también es
igual a 4 entre 9 bueno luego nos
pregunta cuál es la razón entre las
áreas de ambos cuadrados bueno pues el
área de este cuadrado es ex al cuadrado
el área de este al cuadrado entonces nos
piden determinar x al cuadrado entre g
al cuadrado esto es lo mismo que esto es
lo mismo que x entre y elevado al
cuadrado y aquí tenemos el valor de x
entre iu y x entre 64 entre 94 entre 9 y
eso hay que elevarlo al cuadrado y esto
es igual a 10
6 entre 81 entonces x al cuadrado /
llega al cuadrado es igual a 16 entre 81
y por lo tanto la razón entre las áreas
de los cuadrados es 16 16 y 81 la opción
de fantástico a lo mejor hasta cabe otro
problema vamos a ver si no este sería un
poco largo y ya me pase de los 10
minutos sabes que le vamos a dejar hasta
aquí y en el siguiente vídeo continuamos
con el 41